go hi youtubers I'm reporter and author
of The Purpose Driven in that life and
pastor Saddleback Church I'm here at
Davos with a lot of my friends and we're
talking about what are the biggest
problems on the planet now we're going
to solve them right now I think they're
five when I got mobile giants extreme
poverty endemic diseases illiteracy
corruption and the spiritual emptiness
these problems are so big nobody's been
able solvent us I just saw them do it
hasn't solved them nobody solved them
and I think it's because we're going to
take that it's going to take three prong
strategy to do this now there's a role
for the public sector there's a role for
the private sector and there's a role
for the faith sector each of them can do
something that none of the other three
can do government has a role to set
agenda government has a role to set
priorities and things like that and move
nations and there's some things that the
only governments can do businesses have
a role which they have they bring
expertise they bring and they bring
investments they bring all kinds of
innovations to the to the market but
then also houses of worship that things
that businesses and government will
never have in the first place we have
universal distribution the church was
global 200 years of Lord Davos that we
talked about globalization I could take
you to 10 million villages around the
world the only thing in it to church and
we are in more locations the United
Nations who speak more languages than
the aya nation for a thousand more
people groups in the United Nations
you see there's 600 million Buddhists in
the world or 800 million Hindus in the
world there are billion Muslims in the
world but there are 2.3 billion
Christians in the world if you take
people of faith out of the equation you
rule about five six of the world so we
have to mobilize this this faith reduced
faith groups to do take work together on
these issues that that have been
unsolvable and the church has of course
the greatest distribution how's that the
biggest manpower with 2.3 million people
means the church the Christian Church is
better than China further than any
effect it's better
Indians trying to put together so
nothing compares with size you have
hundreds of nines people who volunteer
on the world in villages and cities on a
weekly basis and we're not the pea the
third thing that they have is they have
local credibility at the local level
people trust that priest for that pastor
or for that matter an imam or a rabbi
the religious leader of their faith
because he's marrying he's burying he's
helping them through the stages of life
when the crisis comes NGOs come and go
nations come and go but for instance the
church is a 2000 year track record so I
really think that what we need to do
here at Davos is to work on a
three-legged stool but probably haven't
saw these issues before is because we've
had a few legged stool we've had
government and business trying to work
together and that's a good thing but a
two-legged zoo will fall over you have
to have the faith sector the public
sector and the private sector and
frankly I don't care about why you do
good as long as you do good your motive
may be politics you know I'm a member of
the Council on Foreign Relations and
I've learned that when you for instance
help people get well if they've been
unhealthy or like your nation now that's
not my motivation for doing good but
it's not a bad one if you have a
political motivation fine do it you may
have a profit motivation for doing good
you know some disis say we're gonna
gonna make drugs and make nine same time
help people great I wish more people
would do that I wish more businesses
would make more money and do more good a
same time not my motivation but a profit
mode is not bad you might have a
personal motivation maybe you had cancer
you had AIDS and so you care about
people cancer and AIDS my motivation is
that you just said love your neighbor as
yourself but it don't have to be your
motivation I'm just encouraging you to
get involved do something now about the
problems of the world